this is big Lou and he is one amazing
alligator snapping turtle if you look
inside of his mouth he's got a little
red lure for bringing fish in they got
about 2500 pounds of bite strength he
could bite a two by two right in half hi
I'm Jay Brewer I'm here today to answer
some questions off Twitter this is
reptile support
[Music]
okay at Prince arrived how does a
chameleon change color well that's kind
of a technical question but you know
what I'm gonna get some help with a
chameleon
okay so we got Graco and it's actually a
panther chameleon now if you see they
don't really change color they just
modify the colors that are there by
squeezing open and close and dilating
like your eyeball there's another cool
part about them he has two eyeballs that
work completely independently so he's
actually great at catching his bugs and
insects and look at how beautiful he is
at maggot stomp do alligators chew their
food absolutely not and you know what I
think we'll go feed Darth Gator our
giant gator and you'll see he just
swallows it whole
okay this is Darth and Gomer Darth let's
show them do you chew your food
oh
there you go he doesn't chew his food he
swallows it whole the only time you
would even consider it kind of chewing
their food is the attempt of maybe
breaking the shell of a crab or
something like that at Jack vandertoll
if you were bitten by a venomous snake
would you know what to do unfortunately
I'd really know what to do because I've
been bit by a venomous snake at 23 years
old and it was not a pretty sight some
people actually say the first thing
you're supposed to do is suck out the
Venom completely a myth that Venom that
went in is in end of story truth is when
I got bit the first thing I did was
start sucking the venom out so I thought
my lips started tangling and the
tingling I thought oh my gosh I
shouldn't have sucked it out it got in
my mouth but that's not what happened
the effects of the Venom were already
through my whole system in seconds and
my lips were tingling because of the
venom inside my bloodstream that being
said if you get bit by a venomous snake
the most important thing to do is stay
calm and work your way towards a
hospital as quick as possible at Planet
reptile 23 question for all snake
handlers Wildlife experts handling
dangerous reptiles what type of handling
gear do you commonly use when handling
snakes some kind of snakes are not
venomous so I might take a little risk
and use my hands best tools ever made
end of story that being said if I'm
going to hold something dangerous I'm
going to actually need a little bit of
space something like a pair of tongs we
also use these for feeding big pythons
and stuff because the snake's excited
going after its food then the snake hook
snake hook what it actually is for is
that when this venomous snake that
you're holding drops his head in here
he's no longer can strike left or right
then you got your tongs and that can be
used for a lot of different things for
handling tarantulas scorpions little
venomous animals and also for feeding
small animals it works really well add
James R Us 42. with without cheating
what venomous snake has the longest
fangs in the world wow that's the easy
one I think I should get out a giant
Gaboon viper and show you how amazing
they are this is a gaboon viper got the
longest Fang of any venomous snake in
the world and you could tell that from
that big head and actually has the most
venom to dump at one time not to mention
one of the fastest striking snakes even
has a horn like a rhino Viper they're
closely related both of them have this
incredible pattern and color to hide in
the floors floor in Africa
aaa1e2 R3 wow that one I better go back
to school for it
what's the difference between a gator
and a crocodile anyway a crocodile
generally speaking has a long slender
more v-shaped nose where an alligator's
got that nice u-shaped nose now the
interesting part about that question is
there's actually only two types of
gators in the whole world they actually
come from China and America if it's not
a Chinese alligator or it's not an
American alligator it is an alligator
anyway at Tango 89 how do eyelidless
creatures clean the moisture their eyes
you know what I think I'm gonna cheat on
this one get a subject out to show you
this is George the giant new Caledonian
gecko largest gecko in the world now
geckos a lot of times have eyelids but
they don't close completely this one has
no eyelids and what it does is actually
just lick the their eye like a
windshield wiper kind of wild but then
when you have a snake for instance it
doesn't have eyelids either it gets a
brand new lens every time it sheds
pretty amazing okay at Gram arcade can
reptiles be said to have personalities
absolutely so I have a lot of monitors
lizards and they have a lot of
personality so today I'm going to play
with one of them and let you see what a
rambuctious little critter this
particular one is and maybe we'll get a
second one out and you can see how calm
and relaxed the other one is I'm going
to show you a little mini Dragon that's
got tons of Personality come on come on
come on come on come on here here come
on so we're gonna take them for swim
here we go here we go whoa there we go
so you see every animal's got a little
bit different personality this guy here
is a Pure Swimming hunting wild creature
oh there you go it's great exercise for
animals to interact with people and this
is one of the ways it's called
enrichment to make an animal love its
life I'm going to show you a completely
different personality come on come on
come on so he's pretty laid back so much
so that he won't Chase it like that come
on his name is Fabio and he's just a big
sweetheart he's like more relaxed more
chill here here come on There You Go
Gentle
relaxed just a complete whoa what did
you do
Vanishing chicken
the other guy if I try to do that he'd
have my hand but all of them are very
cool each one's a little bit different
kind of like you at una Mary what if
dragons exist in real life oh God I'm
going to show you some footage of a
giant dragon in Komodo Island look at
this guys it's the most incredible time
of my life this is the peak right here I
don't know if it's going to get better
than this the two biggest lizards in the
island meet up at dinner time on the
beach
wow look at him they exist okay at TNT
gal why do cobras have hoods actually
it's to make them look big and scary
when they jump up they triple their size
they start making a loud noise and it's
going to scare off any animal that's
gonna attack him at swagner are iguanas
dangerous can they bite so the funny
part is I think iguanas are the most
underrated animal for being dangerous
not only they have razor sharp claws
they have an incredible bite because
they have to bite through lettuce leafy
stuff and get a clean cut so unlike a
snake that has really no bite except
long teeth to hang on these teeth are
actually for cutting I've seen some
horrible bites from iguanas but let me
show you how beautiful they are and to
be fair I've seen some amazing pet
iguanas I'm going to show you one that
we've had for many years so this is
actually jolly green he's a rescue
iguana because a lot of people don't
realize iguanas can get big and most
people don't realize that they go in
heat kind of like a dog except that when
a male iguana goes into heat they get
very aggressive and they want to be
dominant and they can bite you severely
that being said they can be great
animals and jolly green is luckily
relaxed and he's about 25 years old
we've had him over 10 years he's
absolutely amazing beautiful animal and
not your normal iguana
at paralfi Komodo dragon saliva kill the
prey actually no they used to say that
the saliva would eventually kill it from
infection but that's not true it's not
the bacteria the actual truth is their
saliva is Venom that is made to paralyze
the animal just long enough for the
Komodo dragon to actually finish it off
and eat it at Janet SK Watson how do you
tell the difference between a python and
a boa okay so boas and pythons are both
constrictors they're both snakes they're
both reptiles but Boas have live birth
and pythons lay eggs and those are all
the questions for today peace out